foreign
comes from Al in Virginia he asks what
is your recommended percentage of income
going into retirement if you're debt
free and you own your home is it still
15 currently I'm right at 30 and I'm 51
years old with north of 1 million
dollars in assets 50 percent of which is
in a 401k is it possible to invest too
much
I love this question and I love where Al
is at financially so if you're tracking
with the baby steps Al is at baby step
seven the final baby step because he has
a paid for home no debt he's got money
in the bank and so at baby step seven
you can invest more than 15 to your
heart's desire it's build wealth and
give and there's no parameters around
that and it's for good reason it looks
different for everyone
so is it possible to invest too much I
think it's a great question because on
one hand on the financial side no you
could have five million dollars you
could have 10 million dollars from
retirement you could have 20 million
dollars it only gives you more options a
bigger Legacy uh and more responsibility
to manage but it's a great problem to
have yeah it really is and again it just
speaks to uh people who are new to this
process when you get a question like
this and you hear this like this is
possible you can do this there's a
reason why there's seven baby steps and
I love that it's a way for many of you
who feel like this is so very far off to
realize it's attainable well and at 51
with a million dollars in assets wow
that's an incredible Milestone it's
probably not enough to retire off of for
the next 40 years if you want to have a
really great retirement so well let's
also point out that he's 51 and then you
know average length of life I mean he's
still got a long way to go in a good way
he's going to keep racking it up 40 50
years ego how much do I need to live and
so A good rule of thumb
is to go how much do I want to live off
in retirement in yearly income multiply
that by 25 and that gives you a really
good number and here's why there's
something called the Trinity study out
there Ken that said if you peel off four
percent of your nest egg every year your
initial balance should remain where it
is nice so if you have a million bucks
you can peel off four percent Without
Really Ever touching that million
dollars that's a great exercise and so
as far as investing too much I would
always caution you to invest more than
you think you'll need because taxes are
going to continue to go up inflation is
going to continue to go up you don't
know what's going to happen in the
future where you're going to want to
live and so I always want more options
versus less now here's why I will say
you're you're investing too much if you
are miserable in your everyday life but
you are at least a great saver but you
your wife wants to go on vacation and he
won't take her even though you don't
have any debt and you've got a million
dollars
that's where I would say let's dial it
back so we can actually enjoy the next
few years of our life while we're still
young and able Let's Travel let's do
those things so if you're allocating to
spending into giving then the rest can
go to saving and you can do that with an
intentionality and no regret yeah I love
that plan and again very simple that
four percent rule is a great rule for
people to get an idea of what I want to
get to so I can live the life that I
think I want to absolutely and uh if you
were going well that feels impossible
because I'm 51 I have nothing saved
there is still hope for you we might
need to reset the expectations of what
we thought retirement would be we might
need to look at a different place to
live to downsize our house to downsize
our life but you can still retire with
dignity if you follow this Ramsay plan
if you get out of debt and have a pile
of money in the bank and you're
investing towards the future future you
can still have a great retirement Here's
a thought just a thought George we we
should probably talk about this sometime
on the show uh
we are seeing Baby Boomers retire at
record rates so we're kind of in the
middle of this and it's going to be
interesting to see over the next five to
ten years
or let's call it 15 years what does the
data show us about these large amounts
of of baby boomers uh retiring because
retiring if it is the notion that it is
I'm not going to ever work again
and um I'm just going to sit around the
house and watch TV take a good afternoon
nap
that's resigning
that I'm old and I'm dying
I I think retiring needs to have a
component of certainly hobbies and
things that you enjoy where you are
active mentally and physically but I
also think it needs to have a level of
contribution and while it may not be
working the same amount of hours
um I I when I look at retirement age it
has has no picture at all with me not
working
am I working less
am I working at a
slower Pace sure
am I playing more and traveling more
absolutely but contributing through some
type of work it's got to be the case and
I just think aging studies if you want
to go look at these things do your own
homework it shows that staying active is
not just go to your swim class at the
YMCA and play golf with the guys on
Saturday morning so I just think it's
really interesting for those of you that
like I'm 51 and I'm just starting you
know what it's possible for you to
enter into retirement age have money
work some
and still have a great lifestyle it's
not all on I gotta just live off the
401K that may be controversial to some
but I just think we're going to see that
that shifts with younger Generations
absolutely and there's only so much on
Netflix before you get bored oh you need
to have a little bit of purpose in life
so great reminders there Ken